Speaker 1: All right. Well, we are starting
today with Hurricane Ian in Florida,
and they don't call it a disaster for nothing.
This is not really a weather show, but there's
been a lot of political stuff revolving around
the hurricane to get everybody up to speed. Many
trapped in Florida. As Ian heads toward South
Carolina reported by the Associated Press.
There are rescue crews, 2.5 million Florida
homes. Per the Associated Press without power, 2.7
million homes without power. According to other
reports, Florida Governor Ron DeSantis told a news
conference, We've never seen storm surge of this
magnitude. It is basically a 500 year flooding
event. When it comes to casualties. Hundreds are
feared dead now. It takes a while to officially
get those numbers. But we now have heard from
multiple political leaders who are saying,
listen, we're being told about dozens, if not
hundreds just in our municipality. So you start
adding that up. And unless everybody's wrong,
you're talking about at least hundreds dead.
The Daily Beast reporting that, as well as
millions more, were plunged into darkness in one
of the most powerful storms in American history.
And then AFP and Yahoo! News reporting floods
devastation after Hurricane Ian hammers Florida.
So there's a couple of different things I think,
that are important to mention here. For a show
like ours. First of all, we see a completely
different Ron DeSantis that I sort of knew existed
in the sense that I've told you all before,
DeSantis is not a stupid guy. His incredible
violent partizanship maybe acute partizanship is
a better phrase, for it is a sort of a calculated
decision. I'm not saying he's not a right winger,
but he can get along with everybody when he
chooses to. And he has said Joe Biden's been good
at helping and everybody's getting along and this
is not the time for pettiness. And again, it's
just another reminder that. It could be like this
all the time if people just want it to be more
reasonable because that's all that's happening.
This and this is just being more reasonable in
part because he knows that his reelection could
potentially hinge on is he seen as handling the
hurricane correctly. In addition, you know, when
COVID started, many of us naively and incorrectly
thought this will bring the country together,
we're all going to unite against the virus. And
then we did. Many Republicans essentially taking
the side of the virus, ignoring all suggestions
and guidelines and recommendations and not getting
vaccinated, all that different stuff. Okay, fine.
With the hurricane, we're just all going. Now
you've got people claiming that the hurricane is
a hoax. Now, what does it mean? What does it mean
that it's a hoax? Some of them say, well, it was a
rainstorm, but it wasn't really that bad. And this
was just a way to get the hurricane in the media
to avoid talking about fill in the blank,
write whatever it is. This was a distraction,
some claiming that it was a geo engineered weather
event of some kind. Again, for whose benefit.
It's like never really completely clear. Others
fixating on the evacuation orders and are they
legal or not and mandatory and all these different
things, folks, it's a hurricane. Okay. Oh,
and actually, I should say some also immediately
fixating on wanting to blame climate change for
this particular hurricane. And as we've
talked about before, climate change is not
really about any particular hurricane, but
climate change models would predict that we
would have more extreme events and that the events
themselves would be more extreme. But I you know,
we don't need to play the game of this particular
hurricane was caused by climate change and
human activities on the planet. We don't need to
do that. The climate change models don't require
that. So I think that that to the extent that
people on the left are doing it also doesn't
make sense. The priority is getting power back
on. Reducing fatalities as much as possible
and starting to get things back together. And we
will let you know how things are looking by Monday